and we're like we're here today guys and
we're going to see the capital
punishment of two Highway robbers who
killed this innocent man's wife and here
they are going to be getting their lims
cut off and hanged now other thugs other
Highway robbers are going to be looking
and thinking that was Bloody so that's
not true do you know why if you're too
dumb not to see that right if you want
to
worship if you want to worship people
like Taylor madon
don't I'm very
hijab was born in this country
[Music]
in we want to establish an amazing
Masjid for the sake of Allah subhana
taala in in the country of Norway click
on the link and donate now for the sake
of Allah subhana tala quickly recount
what I said earlier so for me capital
punishment is wrong because if you if it
turns out the person was innocent then
you've claimed an innocent life and
there might have been a murder but if
they weren't then you've actually killed
someone there's no way to bring them
back and I would say even if I was a
Muslim whether I was Muslim or Christian
or atheist that's too much of a risk
Surly like you wouldn't want to take
that risk with someone's life I want to
hear what you say about that okay
interesting so has a book in this when
it comes to Islamic jur Prudence he
somebody for is um somebody who I follow
um he has a book on Islamic Juris
Prudence so in that book it makes it
very categorically clear that when it
comes to Islam and the capital
punishment people think the capital
punishment is like I'm walking down the
road in a Sharia abiding State and then
I see one guy and he and he is stealing
and I go oh I'm going to go and chop his
hand off it doesn't work like that we
have legal procedures we have witness
statements we have a whole procedure to
go through it's not as simple as oh this
person done a let's go and kill him it
doesn't work like that we don't believe
in vigilantism which go and hunt you
know Bounty Huns doesn't work like that
and the people who try to do that will
be punished why because you went and
killed a soul because he was under the
assump assumption that he killed
somebody we didn't go through the due
process so now you are going to get the
capital punishment for killing someone
that's innocent because we didn't
establish that now Islam is a beautiful
religion why because it deals with
reality I don't deal we don't deal with
Disneyland we don't live live with like
you know we're going to come here and
I'm going to walk down the road with
there's a group of fs and I'm going to
say they shouldn't rob me no they will
rob you it's a system of law it's not
just a religion thank you so it's a
system of law so what Islam does is
Islam says we have worldly problems we
need worldly Solutions on the Divine so
number one there are five Capital
punishments there might be more on
specific things Islam has come to
protect these five things
your wealth your lineage your mind your
religion and
your another one I can't remember so now
the first one is your wealth there is a
capital punishment on somebody that
steals a specific amount the capital
punishment is that their hands will be
cut off you said that do you think
that's Justified that's that's that's
perfectly Justified I explain why would
that be a law you'd want to introduce in
the United Kingdom I I believe if this
law was ride England will be much a safe
place to walk and people will prosper
I'll come to why number two it came to
protect your mind okay came to protect
your and also like for example your
religion that's why there's a capital
punishment on those who apostate trees
them there it's come to protect your
lineage so would you want a punishment
in the United Kingdom for Muslims who
convert for no it doesn't work like that
so if there'll be a capital punishment
there'll be a du process so it's not
about it's not about me wanting it's
about that I believe this the best
solution for the Western World then
there's a capital punishment for
adultery so Islam has come to protect
your lineage so that you know your kids
are your kids yeah so there's a capital
punishment adultery for both men and
women so again this is a law that's you
want to see introduced in yeah yeah 100%
yeah so I believe it's I believe it's
the best thing to happen and I'll tell
you why because now we can talk about oh
that sounds cruel but let's talk about
why to me it does sound sounds very um
you know why because the thing sounds
authoritarian sounds very tyrannical
yeah you know why because we doesn't
mean I support theft and adultery and
all I just think this kind of
punishment I've been to Saudi Arabia yes
Saudi Arabia is a very safe country but
that's also a very brutalized culture to
do that to people Saudi Arabia is a fine
example of much saer country than BR it
is it is but what I will say is this
there is a saying Mercy to the oppressor
is oppression to the
innocent to have mercy on the oppressor
is to have oppression on the innocent so
the P the the logic behind is this I'm
not going to have mercy on a outright
Maniac who's going to come and cause
rape kill St caus the sorder on the land
that's why in Surah MAA in the Quran
chapter 5 it talks about Highway robbers
and it says if you catch them you should
cut off their limbs from either side
left arm right leg right arm left leg
and then you should crucify them now
sounds very sounds medieval medieval no
problem this is the reason why this is
the reason why Islam believes in this we
would rather Capital give a capital
punishment in the most severe way on a
group of FS where you are going on your
business to a trip with your wife and
kids and they stop you in gunpoint and
shoot your wife in the head steal your
money and run away Islam says we will
deal with these individuals in such a
severe way that there's actually vers in
the Quran when it talks about Warfare it
says strike them in such a way that the
ones behind them see and run off the
point is what ISL is here to save life
to preserve life your way of doing it
the liberal way of doing it is they
stole do it again why is it the you're
going to have PS5 in prison you might
have lunch Islam says no let me just
finish this point yeah forgive me for I
just want you to understand I don't want
to do Injustice to it so Islam says the
one who stopped you when you was going
peacefully to your way on a trip shoot
your wife in the head in front of your
kids these people deserve the severest
capital punishment in public so imagine
speakers calling and we're like we're
here today guys and we're going to see
the capital punishment of two Highway
robbers who killed this innocent man's
wife and here they are going to be
getting there limbs cut off and hanged
now other thugs other Highway robbers
are going to be looking and thinking
that was Bloody grome so that's not true
do you know why I don't explain why but
this ISL during during so I think you
know the history of Speakers Corner yes
it's basically um Speakers Corner us cor
they used to have a they used to have a
Gallows it was three pieces of wood in a
triangle raised up on a scaffold and
they would they could hang I think three
or four people on each folks gathering
around I think they only stopped doing
this a couple hundred years ago it's not
that long ago and yet crime was far
worse then than it is now far worse it
wasn't that Capital yeah crime crime in
the in England London was a far more
dangerous place in the 1750s to the
1850s than it is in 2014 uh 24 it's it
was far more dangerous or I think of the
example of United States more dangerous
country more violent crime more thefts
um higher incidence of rape and yet they
have a far more uh capital punishment
Focus system not all the states but many
of them so for me I think we've got to
be careful now on the other hand it's
true that China and Saudi Arabia they
have capital punishment and they are
safer and I and I tell you so I I'm I'm
admitting that it's not like a clear-cut
issue I'm going to tell you but we have
to be very careful and say well look if
someone if someone attacked my wife
killed my wife of course I'd be
absolutely there's no emotion to
describe would you and forgiven there
will be no way to describe the emotion
however I do believe as someone this
might be because of my Christian
upbringing even though I'm not a
Christian now I do think
forgiveness is the appropriate solution
that doesn't mean you let them have
freedom that's interest Allah because
forgiveness is for yourself forgiveness
is about letting go of the anger if you
have someone who carries around anger in
your heart you're going to have a higher
rate of heart attack all kinds of stress
illness so to forgive the person who did
that crime is a way of not saying it's
okay to commit the crime it's a way of
saying for you you're at peace like you
move on and I know in I think in Islam
there's a rule there's a space for that
there's a space for that so there's not
it's not necessarily either all just
think we have to be careful like example
I gave in the UK an innocent man was put
to death by the state after due process
after du process for a crime he didn't
commit now how many people in Saudi
Arabia or in the United States or in
China have been put to death under
Islamic law under Christian inspired
laws under communist inspired laws right
they been put to death wrongly because
and there's no way to come back from
that and I just think you maybe
overlooking the risk involved there okay
so let's break it down a bit because
there's a few points that you mention in
Islam Allah says in the Quran that
there's for example a murder an eye for
an ey so we believe in that an eye for
an eye yeah however Allah says that
there's also blood money that can be
paid that can be at the discretion of
the family so they can also blood money
and number three Allah does say that it
is better if you forgive so Allah saying
it's better if you forgive he was a
peacemaker I is better if you forgive
that's at the discretion of the family
not going to a court and then this
person who committed this massacre or
whatever then all of a sudden the judges
that give this uh the the ruling they do
such an injustice by saying five years
or 10 years and then the family is
distroyed the family is distraught why
because it's Injustice the family's memb
life has been taken they should have the
choice of eye for an eye blood money or
forgiving them so now coming to you made
you made something very interesting I
was thinking about this in certain
situations in America there's a capital
punishment electric chair the injection
all that kind of stuff and sometimes it
doesn't work now I wouldn't say it
doesn't work because Islam deals with a
situation from a micro level to a macro
level which means the following Islam
says we get rid of all kind of
evil around us meaning the following
now again for example a woman being
sexual
objectified there was a study done in
American University where they showed a
group of men half naked girls a women in
bikini the part of the brain that lit up
for two use lit up meaning he saw the
woman as an inanimate object why because
pornography the hypersexualization that
we live in the beauty industry and I
don't have an idea I was driving on the
A6 and I saw a steel company you know
steel metal steel and there was an
inappropriate woman dressed next to her
I'm thinking what the flipping hell has
a still got to do with that woman I was
very I was like what is the correlation
is this woman made sales sales products
now the point is the following what
Islam does it says we are not going to
sexually objectify woman
anywhere nobody so we're saying Islam is
going to make sure but there is zero
reasons for you to even think of doing
evil to any woman zero you can't come
and say oh you know but no no no and by
the way just a disclaimer no way does
Islam say that because a man cannot
control himself the woman needs to wear
the hijab this not from our religion
Islam does not say you are an animal
that's why you just because you're an
animal the woman is to cover up this is
not from Islam of course there's a verse
that says that there might be idiots
that try to you know try to talk in
appropiately look at how many wom I can
bring any woman here and ask them have
you been cat she'll say 100% I've been
cat today maybe 50 times we're seeing
Islam deals with it in such a way says
woman should not be sexually objectified
so therefore now when you R the illness
from the society when a man goes and
tries to rape a woman touch it
inappropriately talk to an appropriate
way there is severe consequences why
because for what perverted reason for
what reason have you decided to assault
this woman you have zero reasons that's
why the capital punishment is so
why now number two when it comes to
theft you have my point about what if
there was due process you have judges
you have the whole system have and yet
there's a mistake I mean humans are fall
we come to that and instead of having
put them in prison and then being able
to release them from prison after
accepting it was a mistake it's too late
you put the man to death your your world
view canot your your world view cannot
answer that but but my world view can
why now I'm going to come to them remind
me that question I'm going to come to
that I think the problem is now you've
avoided the question with all due
respect you've avoided the question
twice all and I'd like you to
face there is room within even Islamic
countries with due process with Islam
law to make mistakes and if they
accidentally put someone to death who's
innocent that's a major stain on the
conscience of that country okay so what
I'm saying it's not an it's not an
accident it's a willful negligible yeah
and I appreciate people who have had
crimes done to them are Furious and
they're angry and that's very
understandable but if it turns out that
actually Mis accuse someone falsely
accuse someone maybe it was a mistake
you didn't you accuse the wrong person
and they've ended up dead there's
nothing to bring that person back you
committed a major crime to your world
view so what I'm saying is the reason
why I'm saying this even if I was a
Muslim I would have concerns over this
i' be very concerned about accidentally
putting to death another Muslim I I will
tell you why not now just want to answer
something I'm not avoiding it this
question you asked you said that there
are countries that have capital
punishment where the crime rate is high
so I had to answer that so I'm answering
that telling you why when you apply
capital punishment to a corrupt Society
of course it won't be a solution so
that's not the model that example that's
a fair argument that is not the model
Islam is bringing Islam is saying we
deal with a problem from the foundations
if you don't deal with if you don't deal
with the foundations my friend I can
have an execution where it cuts a man
slowly slice by slice there'll still be
theft why because the society
holistically is corrupt we Islam says we
deal with the evils in society then you
apply the capital punishment because
otherwise if you for example when it
comes to theft just touch it from that
I'll go to your point when it comes to
theft islamically if somebody holds
money in his hand if he has ,000 in his
hand and he's walking down the road do
you think the person who steals from him
gets a capital punishment I I'm not sure
what this not really you know why
because now you are provoking it's a
it's an act of provocation because why
Islam says a person who breaks into a
house goes to the safe steals a specific
amount saw by seen by a witness gets a
capital punishment because what Islam
says is was he triggered was he poor is
it the state's fault has the state try
look at the context yeah of course
because it goes back to why because
prevention is better than cure we
Islam's model is exactly what you're
saying did now I'm saying in that
instance let's go with now your answer
if they put to death a person who is
innocent now we're seeing there is due
process that the for example do you know
what's the requirements for capital
punishment adultery in Islam uh no I
don't know okay so turning to death
right no no we know what the the how you
execute it it's how do you come to the
conclusion of the
so there was an instance that happened
at the
time Islam yeah so I
thinkl now and actually just before that
I'll just add something the prophet
mhammed upon him once was on his own a
woman came and said I have committed
adultery and I want the capital
punishment this this one my narration it
might sound a bit bizarre so the prophet
moved away from her she said of Allah I
have committed capital punishment and I
would like the capital punishment the
prophet moved away from her now why is
the prophet moving I'm trying to
understand in thisi why is he keep
avoiding them and there was another
instance where a man came and said the
same thing and the prophet said maybe
you just kissed her why is he adding
that word to his mouth the point is the
following Islam doesn't want capital
punishment Islam is not a bloodthirsty
vampire like oh we cannot wait Islam is
here to preserve life but the reason why
the prophet was doing that is to tell
him go and
repent for a woman to be accused of
adultery you need or a man
you need four Witnesses four Witnesses
who say we saw it's it's more witnesses
for a woman than a man right no it's not
it's the same yes this is a big
misconception yeah the capital
punishment for a man and a woman there's
no men gender descrip discrimination
four Witnesses have to say we saw the
penis go inside the vagina like so not
he was on top she was on top did you see
the look if four people come and say she
was on top of him they could all be liar
no they can't because now now telling me
you cannot think of a single situation
where four people can't lie human beings
are not now it's a mass conspirac number
because Witnesses we all know from
studying Witnesses in many cases you'll
have a car crash happen on a street and
the police will go around and interview
10 different people and they'll get 10
different images of what happened and
some of them will outright lie yeah
there's going to be situations like that
now I'm all for someone going to prison
for rape I'm all for that but they do
putting them to death just because four
Witnesses have given an account you're
saying that in every single case those
Witness 100% not going to lie say you're
saying that in every single case
Witnesses have ever given a testimony
they haven't lied so you potentially
putting innocent people to death in the
name of a of a holy book and for me
that's for me I have to say it's it's
barbaric when Christians do it it's
barbaric when any religion does it even
Islam and I I I say that I don't say
that lightly or to be insulting because
I have a lot of respect for many of the
things in Islam and any other religion
but I think we have to be careful this
was a text coming out of the sth century
the prophet was trying to make peace
among tribal cultures that had a very
revenge- based system of thinking right
it was among Arab uh you know tribes of
people and there was a lot of disorder
and he was trying to bring some Harmony
right kind of like gusk Khan bringing
together a lot of the different tribes
in the Steep of Asia I don't see in two
like how many thousand years later how
applicable that is we have to have a
dynamic and like flexible and aware
approach as a way of change we can't
stay fossilized in a particular time and
place right even within Islam you have
very clear um emphasis on growth and
change and on trying to understand
things from different perspectives it's
not like a rigid you know they encourage
debate and discussion which is what
you're all doing here now right um I
don't know you've all grown up in
backgrounds you've got to try and think
where you came why you came to this
perspective is it just because your
parents told you is it just because you
heard it in a book or it's because
someone told you repeatedly as a child
or did you actually come up with it
yourself cuz you weighed up the facts
you know that's why I just say to be
careful you might be advocating and I
don't think you're doing it on purpose
putting people to death and they may be
innocent they may be innocent you
because you're making an assumption that
those witnesses will always be telling
the truth and they may not you've added
that because the thing is just to add on
because I didn't finish my point was
that oh sorry fine it's fine it's fine
just the thought witness is we're
talking about just people okay we're
talking about people who are not known
to be Liars okay what we're saying and
by the way by the way in the sh if you
look at statistics even when was given
by the otoman Empire only in Islam maybe
you will will count with your hands how
many times capital punishment is applied
because you know why it is such a rare
occasion to find a man in a woman if
they going to do they're going in the
house so to find a man and woman in
public in public having intimacy and for
people would all of a sudden come and
see this actually happened at the time
of three companions four of them they
came to him and said we saw this man
having intimacy with this
woman they came to went to all of them
and said did you see it happen said yes
we saw the Peno in the ink we saw the
Peno in the ink we saw the Peno in the
ink they came to the fourth
companion did you see that said did you
see that he said how do you know they
one lying how do you know I'll tell you
I'll tell you why cuz they definitely
saw it now how do you know I'll tell you
why were you there no no I wasn't there
so many many of the had written as his
say they weren't written by Witnesses if
you know anything about you're talking
about the Bible they were say they were
saying M from I heard him tell me that
he said this he said this science behind
I'll tell you so the fourth one said I
think I saw them they all got lashed all
of them got lashed for slander why
because again Islam is not there to
apply it but rather use it as a tool
because now in the western one you talk
about barbarism we're living in
barbarism we're living in barbarism
there are many barbaric things about
Western culture I'm very aware I agree
but that doesn't mean we should adopt
more barbarism to my
friend this is what you're calling
barbarism I'm telling you this is the
solution to your whole problem which is
what how many do you know how many kids
are out there that they don't know their
father and they are committing incest
with their own brother because they
don't know they're in the same vicinity
and their father was a player you
stepped with 20 women impregnated most
of them and are children married each
other from incest you don't need Islam
to fix that problem you need Islam you
can fix that problem without Islam my
friend with all your respect you you are
thirsty for Islam with all du
respect the Western world is thirsty for
the let me tell you what can I ask you a
quick question if the majority of
British people rejected the idea that
you should create Islamic laws in the UK
would you still want to push it on to
the Western public I'm anything to
anybody I'm telling you an idea that
would be a solution for you I'm going
push would you want to use persuasion
and disc or do you want toact it in
Parliament without the conent of even of
democratically if 51% of the Muslims
come and say we want Shar do you know
what happen there'll be a blood buff cuz
the Western world would Fighters for it
and you know that in way quite and you
know that
by the way I'm not saying the West
leaders are innocent Ang what you said
is very fundamental you know why imagine
Christian you don't believe in no democ
I don't believe bran is a democracy one
second you don't even believe democracy
because I said if 51% of the vote was
for Muslims to have a Sharia law there
will be civil war you know why they do
not want it in their country democracy
but when Muslims come and say we don't
want your liberal views on our country
you come and you come democracy is Not
Enough by itself you need human rights
human rights according if if the
majority of if the majority of a
community decided to go and pollute a
river and destroy a river and then
poison the river down liberis do yes and
where Muslims are seeing get out of the
river that doesn't mean that river that
doesn't mean that democracy is always
correct the majority opinion is not
always correct thank you so I AG with
you I agree with you you know what that
means we say this is I I just want
consistency which I appreciate which is
what that if democratically Islamic
Islamic MPS or whatever you call it for
that matter we voted and said we want
the Sharia they would never accept it
you know why is a big lie that we
believe in democracy and freedom of
speech brother they are liars they don't
believe in freed because sh laws they
believe no democracy is not the only
value my friend the only one that's
impeding human rights is the Western
World the Western world is Slaughter
that's just not true I'm sorry let me
tell you you know why the Egyptian
government is treating treat people
brutally do you know what barbarism is
to you let me tell you what barbarism is
to you somebody coming here and hacking
someone to death you're like that's
barbaric I'm like hold on a second do
you know there's 1 million people have
STDs in London that's barbaric can you
imagine 1 million people STDs sexually
transmitted diseases that you're going
to carry on to somebody else that's
barbarism I would encourage everyone to
fact check that I don't know how true
that is you can check it look check that
maybe I'm being generous let's call it
250,000 too many one too many number two
two one how many women are sexually
harassed sexually raped in the Western
World in the western world that is
barbarism how many people who are
walking down the road I can remember
when I was young bro I got robbed three
four times man the ni gold chain there
was a I was Muslim then I could wear
gold chains yeah I got robbed how many
times I know many people who have lost
their lives there's F there robbery and
destruction in Afghanistan and this what
I'm saying you wish even before we
invaded in you have a problem don't
don't us there's crime there's crime all
over the world not just in the west act
as if the West is the only place with
crime is
very West than there is in theic world
you know why because they got laws there
we don't have we don't have the same
you know why because we've been
sexualized the last only and the trans
coming out never used to do that before
but we' been sexualized if you're too
dumb not to see that right if if you
want to
worship to worship people like Taylor
Swift
madon you know the hijab was born in
this country in the 1910 30s and why was
that many as far as I understand from
the Wy do you know why meig Muslim from
my understanding of History there's
nothing about the hijab in the tell it
comes from comes from Portugal comes
from places outside of what
youg listen thisen this
one One V full of Muslims 5,000 Muslims
and you got another Village full of LGBT
people the Muslim village with five
continue the LG well the lesbians aren't
going to have children the the gays
aren't going to be children the trans
have screwed their bodies up the
bisexuals don't know what they're doing
the asexuals don't even want to be there
you know what I mean you should throw
them in prison no I think their Village
will just they'll have no children so
you have 5,000
LGBT yeah so the fertility in turke is
going down as
well you understand the of LGBT they
produce nothing I understand you no no
you made great the reason
is one second I'm saying barbarism you I
tell you what barbarism is by the way if
there's there's a book that I always
recommend to all the females yeah
beautyy the biggest barbarism is to
reduce a woman to a mere sexual object
that the only thing that she believes
she has is her body that is the biggest
barbarism I've seen that a woman has to
go wake up and spend two hours to do
makeup she's afraid and you know there
was a study done by the way when Co was
going on you know we had to wear the
masks guess what women were wearing the
masks even they were told that they
don't have to anymore and they asked him
why cuz he said I don't want to be
judged based on my appearance that is
barbarism that is the greatest form of
barbarism so Islam has come to say as a
woman we have a woman here there's one
sister
here let me tell something this what I'm
saying look you haven't even tested it
what I'm saying is this as a woman I
come and say to the sister you are more
than a sexual object You Are a Human
Being you have so much to off the bloody
Planet not I'm going to go to Brazil get
butt imp plants and die in the proess of
blood mat which happened by the way or
some guy coming and saying I feel like a
piano today I'm a piano I'm going to
marry a tree so the point is when you
have these issues this is the reason why
I say you might call it barbarism but I
swear to God one Highway robot being
executed in speaker Corner when
everybody's watching best bu disgus that
let me tell you something what's more
disgusting is those innocent people
being robbed by those Highway robbers
cuz they get a slap in the hand and play
PlayStation 5 GTA in prison look thank
you very much we'll leave it there
there's probably a million things I
wanted to ask you about thanks guys for
listening it's great
Islam net is raising funds to establish
a Masjid and Community Center in Norway
and they urgently need your support this
donation will be AAR for you because
every person that comes a step closer to
Allah through your donation you will in
be reaping a reward click the link and
donate what you can